have you heard of virtual bagel their
Facebook page has over 4000 likes they
use the page to promote their brilliant
business model we send you bagels via
the internet just download and enjoy it
sounds like a joke and it is sort of
this page was set up by BBC technology
correspondent Rory Kalin Jones in 2012
he wanted to find out what is the worth
of a like on a Facebook page and so he
bought some likes for virtual bagel now
there are two ways to buy likes the
legitimate way and the illegitimate way
the illegitimate way is to go to a
website like boost likes calm and
purchase some likes you can get a
thousand for $70 sites like these use
click farms in developing countries like
India the Philippines Nepal Sri Lanka
Egypt Indonesia and Bangladesh here
employees are routinely paid just $1 per
thousand clicks of the like button so
Facebook explicitly forbids buying likes
in this way instead they offer the
legitimate way to pay for likes by
advertising your page prominently
displayed is a link to get more likes
with a promise connect with more of the
people who matter to you and this is how
virtual bagel got its 4000 likes Rory
Colin Jones paid $100 to Facebook and
the likes rolled in he targeted his ad
to the UK and the United States but also
to countries like Egypt Indonesia and
the Philippines now where do you think
virtual bagel was most popular I'll give
you a hint it wasn't the US or the UK
but within a day he had over 1600 likes
mostly from developing countries now
what was more problematic was the people
who followed virtual bagel looked
suspicious for example there was one
cairo-based follower whose name was
ahmed ronaldo his profile consisted
almost exclusively of pictures of
Cristiano Ronaldo and he liked 3,000
pages Kalin Jones also observed that his
new throng of fans was particularly
disengaged just as you'd imagine those
from a click farm would be but he hadn't
hired a click farm he had paid for
Facebook ads this story was reported in
July 2012 in August Facebook reported
they had identified and deleted 83
million accounts that was 9% of the
total at the time this resulted in
noticeable drops for popular singers and
celebrities so did they delete all of
the fake likes nope not even close I
know because
most of the likes on my Facebook page
are not genuine in May 2012
I received a number of emails from
Facebook offering me $50 worth of free
promotion of my page which at the time
had only two thousand likes my YouTube
channel had 20 times that following so I
thought surely this free paid promotion
could help me reach more of the people
who mattered to me and immediately I
could see the results within just a few
days my likes had tripled and they kept
on growing thousands per day and after a
few months I had 70,000 Facebook Likes
which matched my YouTube subscribers at
the time now what was weird was my post
on Facebook didn't seem to be getting
any more engagement than when I just had
2,000 likes if anything they were
getting less engagement and I didn't
understand why at the time but I've
since realized it's because most of
those likes I was gaining through
Facebook Ads were not from people who
were genuinely interested in veritasium
how do I know
well because fake likes behave very
differently from real followers have a
look at this graph of the engagement of
my Facebook followers now here I'm
plotting countries as bubbles so this is
Canada and the size of the bubble
represents the number of likes I've
received from that country so this is
the United States it's a nice big bubble
now I'm ranking these countries on a
horizontal axis based on what percentage
of the likes have engaged with my page
this month so as you can see roughly 30%
of canadians and americans have engaged
with my page but they are not as active
as the germans we're over 40 percent of
my lifes have engaged and they are not
as active as the austrians a small but
passionate group of veritasium fans at
nearly 60% these are all of the other
Western countries so you can see that
it's common for between 25% and 35% of
my page likes to engage with my page
every month now here is Egypt where less
than 1% of my likes have engaged with my
page now this is India the Philippines
Pakistan Bangladesh Indonesia Nepal and
Sri Lanka that's a big following but no
engagement together all of these
countries make up 80 thousand likes
that's roughly 75% of the total likes I
had before my last video and these are
the profiles that followed me when I
used Facebook advertising and they're
worse than useless here's why
you make a post Facebook distributes it
to a small fraction of the people who
like your page just to gauge their
reaction if they engage with it by
liking commenting and sharing then
Facebook distributes the post or more of
your likes and even their friends now if
you somehow accumulate fake likes
Facebook's initial distribution goes out
to fewer real fans and therefore it
receives less engagement and so
consequently you reach a smaller number
of people that's how a rising number of
fans can result in a drop in engagement
and from this Facebook makes money twice
over once to help you acquire new fans
and then again when you try to reach
them I mean your organic reach may be so
restricted by the lack of engagement
that your only option is to pay to
promote the post
what's worse there is no way to delete
fake likes in bulk all you can do is try
to target posts around them and I should
reiterate I never bought fake likes I
use Facebook's legitimate advertising
but the results are as if I had paid for
fake likes from a click farm now you
might think the solution to all of this
is just to exclude countries with click
farms from your ad campaigns but
unfortunately the problem goes much
deeper meet virtual cat
a virtual pet like none other it's a
page committed to supplying only the
worst most annoying drivel you can
imagine only an idiot would like this
page and that's not just my opinion
that's actually what it says in the page
description and I should know because I
wrote it I created this page yesterday
and then I paid $10 to advertise the
page through Facebook targeted only to
cat lovers in United States Canada
Australia and the UK
now I expected that because I had
excluded all of the big click farm
countries and because the page is so
terrible that I basically wouldn't get
any likes but within 20 minutes I had
blown through my whole budget and I got
39 likes so who are these people liking
a blank page and costing me 25 cents a
piece all of the profiles were from the
places I had targeted mostly the US but
there was something strange about them
all of these people liked a lot of
things like hundreds and thousands of
things and a lot of the things they
liked were odd too like in one account
this person like t-mobile AT&T
and Verizon they like Jeep and Lexus and
Mercedes and Volvo and Volkswagen they
like everything other accounts I saw
they like kitchen scrubbers and they
like mouthwash who reports that on their
Facebook page just I had baffles me
so the real mystery to me is why someone
somewhere would click on ads that they
didn't care about without making money
from them I mean I don't think these
clicks came from bots they're too easy
to identify and eliminate and I also
don't think for a second Facebook would
pay click farms to click on those ads to
generate revenue for them so it really
seems like a mystery and then in this
article I found what I think is the most
reasonable hypothesis click farms click
the ads for free in order to avoid
detection by Facebook's fraud algorithms
they like pages other than the ones
they've been paid for to seem more
genuine I mean you can imagine a
thousand likes on a particular page
coming from one geographic area in a
short period of time would seem pretty
suspicious but buried in a torrent of
other like activity they would be
impossible to identify so workers that
these click farms will literally click
anything I mean where do you think
Facebook's security page is most popular
Dhaka Bangladesh what about Google Dhaka
what about soccer star David Beckham
that's actually Cairo but you take my
point so wherever your targeting
advertising your page on Facebook is a
waste of money
I wish Facebook would remove the fake
likes from my page and from all the
others but that would mean admitting
that they have generated significant ad
revenue from clicks that weren't genuine
which then suppress the reach of pages
who had low engagement forcing those
pages to pay again to reach inauthentic
fans so the truth is Facebook benefits
by maintaining this status quo because
the reality is nobody likes this many
things